[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
heute brauchen wir Gelassenheit und gute
Nerven finde ich denn es geht um
schlechte Horrorfilme ganz schlechte
Musik und vor allem um einen schlechten
Menschen der nichts aus seinen Taten
gelernt hat herzlich willkommen ich bin
Stefan Netzeband und ich bin Mirko
Kasimir wir gehen mit euch diesmal in
das Frühjahr 1993 und nach Sondershausen
in Thüringen hier stirbt der Schüler
Sandro Bayer weil drei seiner Mitschüler
ist so wollen die Bild-Zeitung
rekonstruiert die Geschehnisse von 29
April 93 so
Satans Kinder drei Stunden foltern sie
ihr Opfer im Wald seine Zunge zuckte
gegen den Knebel er stöhnte um sein
junges Leben die letzten Minuten des
15-Jährigen Gymnasiasten Sandro Bayer
ein albtraumtot drei Mitschüler vom
irmisch-gymnasium locken ihn zu einer
Waldhütte Sebastian Hendrik Andreas
jeweils 17 bzw 18 Jahre alt die drei
huldigen Satan sie schwärmen von
Tieropfern jetzt wollen Sie Sandro eine
Abreibung verpassen
Sandro schlägt in der Hütte um sich die
Hütte gehört Hendricks Vater einem
Landtagsabgeordneten eine Vase später
hat Hendrik schreit bist du verrückt
geworden Hendrik rammt ihm sein
Schweizer Messer in den Oberarm Sandro
blutet man bindet ihm den verletzten Arm
ab und fesselte ihn jetzt ist Sandro ein
wehrloses Opfer aber er kann noch
schreiben
die drei Satans Jünger geraten in Panik
sie knebeln Sandro mit der Tischdecke
Sebastian und Andreas ziehen ein
Stromkabel um seinen Hals Hendrik hält
die Füße Sandro röchelt kämpft um Luft
sein Kopf sagt zur Seite Hendrik
massiert sein Herz er will nicht dass
Sandro stirbt aber er ist tot
soweit der Artikel von damals die Bild-
und andere Zeitungen machen aus diesem
grauenhaften Geschehen später den
satansmord von Sondershausen ich finde
das ist im Rückblick keine wirklich
glückliche Wahl weil es die Tat so ein
bisschen ins filmreife verklärt und weil
die Mörder aus diesem Image später sogar
noch Profit geschlagen haben aber
steigen wir mal ein bisschen früher ins
Geschehen ein Merkur okay
Sebastian Schau Seil Henrik Möbus und
Andreas K gehören zu einer auffälligen
Clique die sich schwarz kleidet Kreide
bleich schminkt Black Metal hört Blätter
Videos schaut und nachts auf dem
Friedhof zusammen sitzt und mit Blut
oder Rotwein Pentagramme auf dem Boden
malt sie gucken Filme wie Tanz der
Teufel einen drittklassigen
Horrorstreifen von 1981
ich habe die dunklen Schatten im Wald
gesehen
ich glaube das was immer ich
heraufgesprochen habe mich holen wird
gefallen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nein das waren die Bäume selbst die
Bäume Leben endlich der ganze Wald leben
wie die Journalisten Liane von
Billerbeck und frank Nordhausen später
rekonstruieren Wissen am Ort eigentlich
alle Bescheid die Gruft die Gang macht
nicht nur mit Satans Zeichen wie dem
Pentagramm auf sich aufmerksam einige
der Jungs machen auch Musik in der Black
Metal Band Absatz auch wenn es eine
Zumutung ist hören wir mal rein
[Musik]
oh nein
obwohl die Texte düster und buchstäblich
antichristlich sind darf absurd im
örtlichen Haus der Jugend Proben hier
werden dann solche Zeilen gegrillt ich
stille meine Gier nach Menschenfleisch
dann komme ich in dein Reich niemand
hält das Böse auf im Wald hört niemand
der Opfer Schrei der Bürgermeister sagt
später so habe man wenigstens noch ein
bisschen Kontrolle über die Gruppe
gehabt also man habe gewusst was die so
machen ein sehr spezieller Jugendlicher
ist auch Sandro Bayer er geht aufs
Gymnasium aber die meisten seiner
Mitschüler sind ihm egal er schreibt
einen Brief Freund was denkst du denn
worüber die sich unterhalten und
antwortet selbst über Fußball Bier und
Kümmerling und über Weiber Sandro fühlt
sich außen vor er sieht sich politisch
links und hat manchmal
Ärger mit Neonazis und es gibt etwas das
ihnen mit den Leuten von absagt
auch Sandro ist vom okkulten angezogen
vom schwarzen oder ob meinetwegen auch
vom Bösen aber er findet keinen
Anschluss an die Satanisten Gang bei
ersten Annäherungsversuchen behandeln
ihn die anderen mal wie einen Sklaven
dann wollen Sie Bastian Hendrik und
Andreas wieder gar nichts mit ihm zu tun
haben Sandro revangiert sich indem er
erpressungsmaterial gegen die Satans
junge sammelt und Klatsch und Tratsch
verbreitet so plaudert er am Ort aus
dass teufels-fan Sebastian ausgerechnet
in einer engagierte und verheiratete
Christin verliebt sei die Umstände für
eine freundschaftliche Annäherung sind
also eher ungünstig
[Musik]
umso überraster war Sandro
wahrscheinlich als ihn im April 1993
eine Mitschülerin aus der Clique auf dem
Schulhof einen Zettel zu steckt darauf
steht 20 Uhr am Rondell abends bevor er
losgeht erzählt er seiner Mutter
Cornelia ganz nebenbei er sei verabredet
mach dir keine Sorgen ich bin gegen
viertel nach Neun wieder da vom
Treffpunkt am Rondell wird Sandro zu
einer Hütte gelockt zur Laube der
Familie Möbus und hier passiert nun was
die Bild so detailliert aufgeschrieben
hat Sebastian Schau Seil Hendrik Möbus
und Andreas K quälen ihr Opfer zwei
Stunden lang dann ziehen Sie ein Kabel
um Sandros Hals und drücken zu bis er
nicht mehr atmet als der 15-Jährige auch
am späteren Abend nicht heimkehrt macht
sich die Mutter natürlich große Sorgen
aber noch während Cornelia Beyer und ihr
Mann überlegen wo ihr Sohn abgeblieben
ist verscharren ihn seine Mörder in
einer glaube in der Nähe der Hütte
allerdings ist hier kein besonders
schlau geplanter Mord passiert innerhalb
weniger Tage geraten die Satanisten rund
um Henrik Möbus ins Visier der Polizei
erst wird ein blutiges T-Shirt von
Sandro gefunden später machte mit Täter
Andreas K auf Druck der Polizei eines
Skizze von der Stelle an der Sandro
verschärft wurde als Sebastian verhört
wird gesteht er die Tat fast sofort mit
Rüger Stimme erklärte einem Beamten
sachlich wie es abgelaufen ist in der
Hütte der Familie Möbus und behauptet
das ist kein bestimmtes Motiv gegeben
habe aber die Clique habe schon vor
längerem beschlossen Sandro aus dem Weg
zu räumen und er also Sebastian habe
ohnehin wissen wollen wie so ein Mord
sich denn wohl anfühlt als die drei
Jugendlichen dann vor Gericht stehen
widerruft Sebastian seine Aussage auf
seine beiden Freunde sagen jetzt das
Ganze sei eher ein Unfall gewesen man
habe Sandro einschüchtern aber nicht am
Morgen wollen der Richter Jürgen
schuppner muss nicht nur die Absicht der
Täter einschätzen also den Umstand ob es
sie einen Vorsatz gab oder nicht er
versucht auch den satanistischen
Hintergrund einzuordnen erhält am Ende
folgende Einschätzung fest über die
Teufelsanbetung der Mörder wir sind
davon überzeugt dass die Tat ohne diesen
Hintergrund nicht möglich gewesen wäre
ganz egal aus welchen Motiven sie sich
damit beschäftigten sie haben die
Achtung vor dem Menschen vor seiner
Würde verloren
vor Gericht wird noch mal der Film Tanz
der Teufel hervorgehoben weil er als
Vorlage gedient haben soll sowohl für
den Mord als auch für das Vergraben der
Leiche im Film wie in Sondershausen
wurde das Opfer in ein Bettlaken
gewickelt und im Wald nahe einer
Holzhütte vergraben Hendrik Möbus
verkaufte außerdem schwarz kopierte
Horrorfilme und er schrieb sehr brutale
Kurzgeschichten
die Staatsanwaltschaft fordert für jeden
der Täter zehn Jahre Freiheitsstrafe
Sebastian schausseil und Hendrik Möbus
werden schließlich am 9 februar 1994
wegen gemeinschaftlich geplanten Mordes
Freiheitsberaubung und Nötigung als
Haupttäter im Prozess vor dem
Landgericht Mühlhausen zu 8 Jahren Haft
verurteilt Andreas K wird als Mitläufer
betrachtet und kommt mit sechs Jahren
davon das Gericht bleibt mit den
Urteilen unter den zulässigen
Jugendstrafen es will den Jugendlichen
die Rückkehr in ein normales Leben
ermöglichen alle drei Satanisten kommen
in die Justizvollzugsanstalt Erfurt wo
sie im gleichen Bereich untergebracht
wurden obwohl das Gericht auf eine
getrennte Unterbringung der drei
plädiert hat ein Fehler denn Andreas
Hendrik und Sebastian distanzieren sich
nur zum Teil und offenbar auch wirklich
nur zum Schein von ihrer Tat einerseits
schreibt Sebastian einen Brief an den
sondershausener Pfarrer Jürgen aus
Keller der Sandro damals beerdigt hatte
Sebastian bitte darin um seelische
Unterstützung des Geistlichen
Unterstützung bei der Verarbeitung des
Mordes andererseits dürfen die Täter im
Gefängnis ihre Band weiterführen
allerdings heißen sie jetzt nicht mehr
abserved sondern in Ketten sie nehmen
eine Kassette auf und veröffentlichen
sie auf dem Cover das Grab des
ermordeten Sandro Bayer mit dem Zusatz
the cover shows the grave of Sandro
birdet bei Hort absurd on twenty nights
of April 19 ABB was für eine miese
zynische und beschissene Schweinerei die
gefühlskalten Mörder von Sandro dürfen
ihren kranken Dreck verbreiten und es
finden sich genug Leute die diese
Mischung aus Satanismus und neonazikult
cool finden denn als das entpuppt sich
besonders Hendrik Möbus sehr schnell als
Rechtsradikaler ohne jeden ethischen
Kompass schon 1998 kommen die Mörder
frei Hendrik Möbus wird am 25 August des
Jahres als Letzter entlassen nachdem er
bei einer Anhörung den Mord noch mal
ausdrücklich bedauert hat nur einen
Monat später tritt absurd wieder unter
altem Namen auf und Möbus zeigt auf der
Bühne den Hitlergruß er wird gleich
wieder einkassiert und sitzt weitere 8
Monate ab die Justiz muss schnell lernen
was für ein uneinsichtiger
faschist-möbus ist als nächstes nennt er
Sandro in einem Interview volksschädling
da wird ihm die Bewährung gestrichen er
flüchtet in die USA und taucht dort bei
befreundeten Neonazis in West Virginia
unter aber der internationale Haftbefehl
aus Deutschland wird auch hier nicht
vergessen im August 2000 wird Möbus
festgenommen und die Behörden bereiten
seine Auslieferung nach Deutschland vor
Möbus und seine us Freunde stellen ihn
als Opfer politischer Justiz dar es wird
ein Asylantrag gestellt auf einer
solidaritätsseite im Internet werden
Unterschriften für ihn gesammelt es
machen sich gleichzeitig Leute für ihn
stark von denen sich später herausstellt
dass sie V-Leute für den deutschen
Verfassungsschutz sind zum Glück nutzt
es nichts Möbus wird ausgeliefert und
fährt in Deutschland wieder ein über
deutsche Neonazis und die Versäumnisse
der Sicherheitsbehörden da ließen sich
sicherlich noch viele Podcast machen im
Fall Möbus gibt es noch viele eklige
Details er sitzt seine Strafe bis 2007
ab schreibt immer wieder Texte für die
Band absurd noch Jahre später macht er
wieder Musik verkauft widerlichen Nazi
Merch und muss immer wieder mal beim
Staatsanwalt Vorsprechen ein
unbelehrbarer völlig kaputter Typ
anders als die Mittäter von Andreas K
wurde seit dem Verbüßen der Jugendstrafe
nichts mehr gehört Sebastian Schauseil
studierte später Jura und ging
anschließend in Thüringen in den
Schuldienst das sorgte erst vor kurzem
noch mal für Schlagzeilen Satans Mörder
darf weiter für Schulamt Arbeiten titelt
die Bild im November 2022 dabei
herausgekommen dass der ehemalige Mörder
von Sandro Bayer jetzt für die
Hortbetreuung Tausender Kinder im
Schulamt Ostthüringen zuständig ist ich
muss gestehen dass ich das bei weitem
nicht so schlimm finde wie die
fahrschulkarriere des Hendrik Möbus ich
meine der sebastian hat seine Strafe
abgesessen und dann eigentlich getan was
die Gesellschaft von ihm erwartet hat in
ein normales Leben gefunden
ja das sehe ich auch so Stefan wobei
solche Nachrichten für die Eltern des
Opfers sicher bis heute schwer zu
ertragen sind das war auf jeden Fall
unser Fall für heute wir haben ihn
erzählt mit Artikeln aus Bild und Welt
so wie Erkenntnissen aus dem Buch
satanskinder von Liane von Billerbeck
und frank Nordhausen Skript Stefan
Netzeband Postproduktion weight watch
Studios München bis zum nächsten mal
euer Mirko und euer Stefan